BRANDON BADGER: All right.
Come on in.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Brandon.
I can't tell you what my real
last name is, but let's just
say that it's Badger.
I've worked for the NIA, and my
more recent cover is as a
"Product Manager" for Google.
All of you in this room are
chosen, have been pre-screened
to share this confidential
information.
As you can imagine, this is a
very sensitive topic for a
corporation like Google since
we're dealing with mind
control viruses and shapeware
technology
from another dimension.
It is very important that none
of this information leaks to
the press, so for that reason,
the real Ingress Tech Talk,
the official one, is happening
in Room Seven, but that
government-censored talk will be
the one that's recorded and
we'll get into the real details
here in this room.
And we'll dive deeper into
rabbit hole in this room.
But before we start, can I see a
show of hands of how many of
you are members of
The Resistance?
All right.
And how many of you are members
of The Enlightened?
[CHEERING]
BRANDON BADGER: All right.
Now, you two settle down.
I know this is a lot of Smurfs
and frogs in the same room,
but this is considered neutral
territory during this talk.
So I want all of you to put your
scanners in your pockets.
It's very important
to not fire any
XMPs during this meeting.
In the event that there is an
accidental XMP discharge,
please exit the room swiftly but
calmly from the rear and
any Level Eights can leave
with me through this more
secure door up front.
All right.
Let's get started.
For the sake of this tech talk,
we're all just going to
go under the premise that
Ingress is "just a game." And
I can't teach you all in 30
minutes all of the technical
aspects of building ingress, but
my goal today is more to
spark your creativity and talk
about some of the product
design principles and lessons
learned that our team has had
developing Ingress.
And my hope is that you will
leave Google I/O within
exposure to lots of new
technologies and Google Glass,
all the other cool things that
you've seen today and will see
tomorrow, and that you also have
lots of creative ideas
for the next generations of
games that you yourselves and
your friends can build using
this technology.
So my first quote is that
"with change comes
opportunity." Throughout
history, we've had many
technological leaps forward.
We had the semiconductor, we've
had the steam engine.
If you go back further in
history, we have the time when
our ancestors first found the
obelisk and it kick started
our creativity.
And humans have always played
games, but the way that we
play games has evolved.
So we might have started off
kicking rocks, and then it got
a little bit better and we could
bat a rubber ball around
in the king's court, and then
that turned into the digital
version upon of Pong.
We get Nintendo tennis there.
But as technology marches
forward, the gaming technology
marches forward in step with
that, and each generation of
games has its leaders.
In one generation, it might
have been Atari.
Later, it might have been
Nintendo, then Sony.
But with each leap forward
in technology, there's
opportunities to take over, to
be a leader in that new space,
to design whole new types
of gaming experiences.
For example, there was a man
who in 1961, invented the
transistor-transistor
logic circuit.
And I'm sure that when he was
working on this for his
dissertation and invented this
technology, he wasn't doing it
so that we could play an
electronic version of tennis.
But 10 years later, the gaming
industry was able to use this
technology and create a whole
new gaming experience.
Things like the Wii Remote.
Seemed like Nintendo was kind of
in a lull there, it was all
about the Sony PlayStation, but
they used this technology
to really come up with something
completely out of
the box and a whole new way of
playing games in a much more
physical manner.
You had examples of the social
graph as a technological tool,
being able to interact
with other people.
Even though in this case, it was
limited to sharing virtual
baskets of corn or whatnot, so
I don't know how much of a
technological leap that was,
but there was something
powerful and being able to
interact with other people--
friends and your
mother-in-law--
as you play a game.
And it seems like the smartphone
generation just
came out of the blue as well.
You had companies like Sony and
Nintendo who had really
dominated with consoles, and
they tried to have their
portable gaming devices.
But all of a sudden your Nexus
device, your iPhone became a
much better gaming platform for
that type of snack type
gaming, and you had all the new
leaders like Angry Birds
create new experiences.
So basically, I wanted to just
show you that there's these
technological leaps and each one
of those is an opportunity
for you and your company and
your friends to create
something that the world hasn't
seen before in gaming.
We live in a really powerful
environment right now where
these smartphones are getting
out to the hands
of billions of people.
So you have billions of people
now with this supercomputer,
basically, in their pocket
that's connected to the
network and it has all
sorts of sensors.
It's got a proximity sensor
and a motion sensor, an
ambient light sensor gyroscopes,
NFC chips,
cameras, GPS, Wi-Fi.
These are all ingredients that
you guys are going to be able
to put together in whole new
ways to create whole new types
of experiences, and
we're really just
starting to tap into that.
It's not all about just
doing Angry Birds.
So I just want to really
challenge you guys to, as you
spend time in Google I/O today,
really think about the
technology that you see whether,
it be Google Glass or
other devices.
Just think through, what new
types of gaming experiences
can that make possible?
How can we experience
the world in a
different way via gaming?
I just want to take one step
back and just talk about why
do humans play, and why
is this a field
that should even matter?
There's so many other important
things in the world
that we could be using
technology for, but why does
play matter?
First of all, play creates
new neural
connections in the brain.
It helps us develop.
I've got two twins
and it's amazing.
They're five years old now, but
they can play Angry Birds
and Plants Versus Zombies and
all these different things,
and it's just it's a way to form
connections in the brain
and learn about our
environment.
It's also an arena for social
interaction and learning.
It's sort of on the schoolyard
where we learn how to make
friends and to confront that
bully and to make alliances
and factions and connect with
other human beings.
That's an important social skill
for humans that we learn
while playing.
It's also a safe place to
discover and develop talents
and skills.
So sort of like in Ender's Game,
gaming can be a safe
environment or a safe simulation
for you to maybe
learn leadership skills.
We've seen this in Ingress where
there's people who are
organizing their own events or
organizing the tactics of
their squadron or
their faction.
It might be learning other types
of skills, how to just
organize plans and implement
those or execute events.
So gaming really gives us a safe
environment where, if you
mess up, it's not that
big of a deal.
You can restart the game.
But you can still build these
skills and then use those
skills in your day
to day life.
But in many ways, games
still fall short.
So while they might make us
smarter, I don't really want
my twins to be playing video
games all day long
necessarily, right?
And I don't want my kids doing
that if it means they're going
to be sitting in the basement
eating Cheetos and playing
first person shooters all day,
tethered to a screen.
So we wanted to think about,
how can we make gaming even
better for humanity and
more interesting?
So that's where Niantic
Labs came into being.
We're a small autonomous group
within Google, and we were
formed with this mission to
create adventures on foot.
When we started off, the team
really wanted to explore
opportunities to use this
new technology--
things like Google Glass, things
like these smartphones
with really great maps behind
them, and really think about
how we could use augmented
reality to create a new gaming
experience.
And honestly, we really
did want to get
people off the couch.
It's a really important epidemic
in many developed
countries, just health and the
importance of getting out and
not being stuck to a chair.
And also, to reconnect people
with their local community.
So technology can bring us
together, but it can also
isolate us if the technology
isn't developed right where we
spend more and more time at
home at night playing with
virtual friends but
not really rubbing
shoulders with real people.
We don't need to necessarily
be tethered to a desk by
technology.
Technology should help
further our needs and
our goals as humans.
It should make us better.
We don't need to necessarily
adapt who we are as people to
the technology.
I think there's a great
opportunity
for contextual computing.
So when I was a kid, I would
write a book report about a
European city or I might
just read a book about
it and write something.
But how much better is it to
actually visit that city but
then have at your fingertips
access to the world's greatest
encyclopedia of information
about exactly
where you're standing?
So at your fingertips, the
information about that
sculpture, that statue, that
mural that you're right in
front, and how interesting could
it be that that's maybe
pushed to you?
You don't even know that you're
interested in that
sculpture, but this smart system
can basically detect
that you're standing near
something that we think that
you might be interested in
and be able to push that
notification to you.
And for you to have an aha
moment is very powerful as a
concept to us.
Here's an example of someone at
a historical grave marker
to be able to pull up more
information about that person.
So it's another way to not
only connect with people
around us, but also connect
with our history and our
culture, which is also
very important.
And this is just a funny joke.
I don't even know who created
it, but someone on the
internet posted this to G+.
The mom is telling the kid,
go outside and play.
And he's like, but I don't have
my Ingress invite yet.
So we definitely wanted to try
to build a gaming experience
that would get kids and adults
and families back out into
their neighborhoods and out,
honestly burning calories and
exercising.
Another goal was this feeling
that we could get people out
into their neighborhood
and connecting
with their local community.
So there was a really touching
post that one of the Ingress
players posted about
this park.
This is a park in Las Vegas, and
I guess he had lived there
for six years but had never
gone into this park.
It wasn't in good repair, it was
closed at night, it wasn't
seen as safe.
But as soon as he started
playing Ingress, of course
there were some sculptures in
this park, and so there were
some portals in our game.
So he went through that park
for the first time and he
discovered it was actually a
nice, quiet green space in his
city, but now he
cared about it.
Now he wanted to talk to his
city councilmen about, hey,
maybe we can clean
up the graffiti.
Maybe we can work to keep
it open at night.
And so I think there's a real
opportunity that when you get
out of your basement and you
start intermingling with other
people in your local community,
that you start
caring about the locations
in your community.
So that was another important
goal for our project.
So let me tell you about-- it
seems like you guys are all
into Ingress, but for the few
of you who haven't played it
and don't know what I've been
talking about for the last 10
minutes, I'll briefly go through
what Ingress is, and
then I'll talk about some of the
design principles and what
we've learned building it.
So the world around you
is not as it seems.
The whole point of Ingress is
that there's this veil that
blocks our vision about what's
really happening, and those of
you who are chosen and are sort
of part of this secret
society have the technology to
be able to unlock and see
what's happening beneath the
covers, and basically play the
game of Ingress throughout
your daily life.
So the fiction here is that
there's a mysterious energy
that has been unearthed by a
team of scientists, and really
its purpose and force is
unknown, and it has a way of
influencing us.
It's said that it's actually
what sparks the creativity in
the minds of artists.
When they go to create a
sculpture, that creative
influence comes from the XM
that flows around there.
And in Ingress, there's of
course the two sides.
There's The Enlightened who seek
to embrace the power that
this energy may bestow
upon us.
They like the idea that as
humans, we can evolve, we can
get better.
And then The Resistance.
They struggle to defend and
protect what in their mind is
left of our humanity.
They really want to keep
us who we are.
They feel like we don't
need to change.
And really, the idea here is
that the world is a game.
So instead of just playing on
a small virtual world or a
virtual board, we really
have the whole globe.
That was one of the powerful
aspects of our game was
launching it worldwide, and
it's so fun to see the
international nature
of the game.
Basically, as you walk around in
the real world, you pick up
the XM, the energy to power
your technology.
You visit these portals or these
public art installations
and you do battle for control
of these locations.
And one of the interesting
things as we were designing
the game was thinking about,
well, what should be the
locations that people
can test?
And I think it was interesting
that we picked public art.
It worked out well because they
tend to be in locations
that are accessible, usually
day or night,
relatively safe locations.
And also, it's just a bonus that
they're very interesting
and oftentimes overlooked.
I've noticed that by playing
Ingress, all of a sudden, I'm
noticing sculptures that I never
would have seen before
because my eyes are opened
to looking for that.
And it's a cool experience to
find something new in your
neighborhood.
Maybe you've walked that street
hundreds of times but
never really looked about what
you were walking past.
So it was an interesting synergy
there to combine this
game element of a portal
with real world art.
And then the basics
of the strategy.
It continues to evolve and get
more interesting and complex,
but the basics of it are to
control these locations on the
map and then create lines or
links between them which can
form a triangle, which
is a Control Field.
And the idea is that you're
trying to control the minds of
the humans who live under that
Control Field, and so the
scoring is based upon the
population data under those
Control Fields.
So if you build a really large
Control Field in the deserts
of Nevada, it's not going to
be worth as many points as,
say, if you were able this
weekend to build an amazing
Control Field over the
population of San Francisco.
One of the fun elements of the
game is that we have an
Investigation Board.
So this is at
nianticproject.com, and every
day, we post new elements
of the story.
These might be video clips.
They might be redacted CIA type
documents that fill in
all the pieces of the story
and the back story.
It's an interesting storytelling
medium.
It's very different than just
reading a book cover to cover.
It sort of unfolds day to day
and you sort of dive right
into it to get a sense of this
alternate universe that's
happening around us.
And then there's also a gaming
element to it as well where
there are puzzles and passcodes
hidden in it that
you can unlock to power up
in the regular game.
And then another fun element of
Ingress is this ability to
form alliances, and it's been
fun to see people cooperating
across neighborhoods and
cities and countries to
exchange portal keys and to work
together at these large
events and really meet
each other in person.
So that's sort of the basics of
Ingress, and hopefully you
all get a chance to
play it this week.
We have a number of events
happening concurrently with
Google I/O, and so come visit
us at our desk there to get
more information about
the schedule.
So now I'd like to take a step
back and talk about some of
the key learnings that our team
had developing the game
and also seeing it unfold
as we've launched
in this beta period.
There's a lot of stuff that we
didn't even think about in
advance that we've learned
through this period that can
be applicable to you guys, as
many of you guys are game
designers or game developers,
that can help you as you think
about the types of games that
you want to build, whether it
be using Google Glass or the
latest Nexus phone device.
So one of the things that was
interesting is just how the
two elements of the game-- you
have the story, but then you
have the game mechanics, so
the rules, the things that
you're allowed to do.
And it was really interesting to
see how adjusting the game
mechanics has a direct
impact on how social
your game can be.
So for example, we started
testing the game with
Googlers, I think back in August
of this last year, with
a much smaller group of people
who are Google employees.
And in the first version of the
game, one individual could
power up a portal, basically,
to the full
power on their own.
So constantly during this alpha
period, we've making
adjustments.
So it's very interesting to see
when we had the insight to
change the rules such that you
actually needed eight players
now to build the highest level,
the most powerful
portal, it was really fun to
see all of a sudden it
instantly went from players
playing on their own around
Mountain View campus to these
squads of groups of eight
Googlers roaming in packs
at lunch time.
So it was very powerful
and it was instant.
It was the next day, you
saw this change.
So the learning here was just,
if that stickiness of that
cooperation is something that
you're looking for, you can
definitely think about ways that
you can tune your game to
encourage that type of behavior
that you want to see.
Another thing that we've learned
is just the importance
of balancing and tuning all
the various variables.
So I think the key learning
here that we had is the
importance of investing the
engineering work to make all
of your variables configurable
knobs that are easy to change
without an update
to your server.
You want to be able to tune
these things really quickly
and do it based upon feedback
from your players.
And it takes a little bit more
work to architect your
software such that you can do
that, but it's also really
nice because then you could have
people playing more of a
game design role--
maybe not your engineering
team--
who then can use an
admin console to
change the various values.
Because it can dramatically
change the playability of your
game, just with these variables
that you do.
So for example, attack
versus defence.
That's something that we're
always fine tuning and it's
very hard to get right.
How difficult should it
be to defend a portal
once you have it?
If you make it too difficult
to defend, you very quickly
can get just a static game board
where everything just
locks up and any new players,
they can't do anything.
There's no turnover.
And if you err on the other side
and make it too easy to
attack, then there's this sense
that what's the point?
I built this great Control
Field, these portals, but it's
so easy to take down.
That doesn't feel fair either.
So you're constantly
going to need to
balance things like that.
And you're also going to need
to tune all the variables as
far as, how do you balance the
magnitude of the power of a
high level player versus
a low level player?
You're constantly going to be
having, in a game like this,
new players joining
this world.
They need to feel powerful
enough that they can have fun,
but at the same time, you need
to reward the players who have
invested the time developing
their skills and building
their capabilities so that they
can feel like they are
more powerful.
So that's something that
you'll need to balance.
And as I said, we think it's
important to build a social
experience.
Not every game has to be social,
but we've found with
our data, as we look at our
retention rates and activity
with players as they progress
through the game, that those
players who come to these
events, who make friends with
their faction team members,
they actually stick in the
game a lot better.
So that's an interesting insight
for you guys as you
design your games because you
want to get as many new
players to start your game as
possible, but you also want as
many as possible to stick
around and continue
to play your game.
So for example, I don't
necessarily
play Angry Birds anymore.
I'm over that.
There's a lot of games
like that.
So it's very easy to design a
game that's fun for a few
days, maybe, but it's much more
difficult to design a
game that people will continue
to play over and over again.
And so this was just one of the
things that we've learned
is that we've found with our
data that if you can build a
game where people can make real
friends, I think people
stick around and will
play much longer.
And I felt like this was very
rewarding to just see people
meeting each other, having
beers together, and
meeting in real life.
There had been a lot of talk
over the last couple of years
of "social gaming," and it was
more in a context of Facebook
games and things like that.
But to me, this feels real.
This feels like a much different
experience where
you're meeting people
in real life.
This was just another thing that
sort of shocked us, was
just the creativity
of the community.
We did this thing that when we
launched the game, we weren't
sure exactly how much server
capacity we had, so we decided
to use a beta approach
where we'd have an
activation code system.
And at first, we started off
where you would just submit
your email address at
ingress.com and as space was
made available, we would send
you an email with the
activation code.
But we had this insight on G+.
We saw a fan basically create
some artwork for Ingress, and
so we had this insight
to reward him with
an activation code.
And it sort of just snowballed
from there where fans started
posting all sorts of artwork
in exchange for these
activation codes.
So we found that the fans who
went through that process,
they were also much more likely
to stick around with
the game because they had
invested something in it.
They'd sort of embodied some of
the fiction and the story
elements before they had
even started the game.
So I don't think every game
needs to do that, but for us,
we felt like it was definitely
a positive experience having
that and just seeing that
creativity of the players in
the community.
This was actually an example of
an image that fans created,
and I just thought it was just
a cool piece of artwork.
But this was in the context of
you sort of describe the
attributes of the
various levels.
So you had a new player who was
just starting out, maybe
didn't quite know the optimal
strategy for deploying
resonators or for linking
portals together.
He might have been that annoying
new player that put
the link in the wrong spot that
blocked your really great
link that you were planning.
And then you had players
progressing, and they kind of
got the hang of it.
Maybe they had a few friends.
Maybe they belonged to the G+
local community, and so they
were strategizing
on the weekend.
And then you had your Ninja
Level Eight player who had
built his own wearable harness
for his scanner
and all these things.
So I think it is important to
build a game where you feel
like there's this progression.
We're still tuning this
ourselves, but you can make it
fun for a new player, but also
make it something that players
don't get bored of too easy
and they can continue to
progress as well.
This is really basic to gaming
design, but one way to think
about it is there's lots of
different types of people,
different types of psychology,
they play games
for different reasons.
So we have an example
here of Bartle's
Taxonomy of Player Types.
On the y-axis on the upper
left, you have Killers.
So these are people who really
just get a sick pleasure out
of destroying your portal or
attacking your field, not that
there's necessarily anything
wrong with that.
And then on the lower left,
you have Socializers.
So that's the equivalent of
beer league softball where
you're not there necessarily
to win.
You're there to have some beers
with your friends and
play and meet new people and
have fun, and that's a great
way to experience
games as well.
On the lower right, you
have the Explorers.
So in a game like Ingress, these
are the people who just
really love finding the new
artwork in their city and
exploring new types of areas,
but also exploring new
experiences, meeting new
types of people, that
kind of thing as well.
And then achievers.
So to the extent that there
are missions, they want to
accomplish all the missions.
They want to get to Level Eight
as quick as possible.
And that's a different
type of player.
So I'll talk about how we think
about these different
groups for the game.
Your game doesn't necessarily
have to hit square on in any
of these quadrants, but it's
nice to think about this, to
think about ways your game can
reach a broader audience and
you have different ways
of playing your game.
So for example, Portal Discovery
is almost a game in
and of itself.
So in our game, we use public
art installations or
architecture or murals as
the locations, and we've
outsourced that and let the
players, you guys, themselves,
find this art and take photos of
it and upload it, but that
in itself is a game.
When I was traveling, I was in
Park City skiing this last
winter, and we didn't have
as much portal data.
So I just spent an afternoon
walking down Main Street there
in Park City, and there was
all these sculptures, and
taking a photo.
It was actually a really fun
way to experience a new
location and it became a
game in and of itself.
So this really scratches the
itch for that explorer type
personality.
And it's also reaching different
demographics.
I think this appeals
to people that you
don't think of as gamers.
This isn't first person shooter
type thing, but it's
just a fun way to experience
the game.
Another element that we're
working into Ingress is sort
of a collect them all
type element.
In a lot of ways, these Portal
Keys are tradeable and
interesting.
I think back to G+ and Facebook,
people really like
those maps where it's all the
countries you visited or all
the states you visited.
And whenever you see something
like that, we have this
impulse to fill in whole
map, or we want to
collect them all.
And Portal Keys are kind
of like that, too.
I like this idea of having
missions where maybe you're
here in San Francisco
for the weekend.
I feel like it would be kind
of fun to be like, can you
collect a Portal Key from each
of the 20 most iconic
locations in San Francisco?
I feel like that in
itself is a game.
It has nothing to do with
battling The Enlightened or
The Resistance, but it's sort
of an offshoot of the game
that's fun in and of itself.
It's also funny, we've seen
examples of people trading
Portal Keys in airports.
So it was very international
drug trade kind of thing going
on, where people were meeting at
Chicago O'Hare airport and
you had one guy flying from one
city, and then he'd drop
of the Portal Key.
Another guy would pick
it up and transfer
it to another city.
So very cool to think of these
virtual drops, these drops of
virtual items.
You could almost imagine
them flying in
their luggage on airplanes.
There's something cool about
how, I went to Paris and I
brought back the Portal Key from
the Eiffel Tower, and you
can show your friends.
So I think that's
an interesting
way to play the game.
Another interesting thing that
we learned is that players can
help build the game.
The "Who the bleep suggested
this portal," that was a
really popular meme on G+.
So there's all the
Ingress-related posts that
happened there, and that
was one of the
most re-shared ones.
I thought that was funny.
So we launched these tools
in the game where
you can snap a photo--
that first photo is our office
in Venice, California, it's
like this binoculars thing--
any sort of interesting
architecture or art.
And also, users, in addition to
submitting a portal to help
build out the game set, you can
suggest edits to the title
or the description or you can
submit a better photo and that
kind of thing.
It's interesting.
The talk before this talk was
the talk from the Google Maps
team, and they have also used
this a lot, too, where if
Google Maps has your street
labeled incorrectly, you can
go to Google and you can edit
that, and everyone's
contributions build up and
they add to a better
experience for everyone
in the game.
We know that our portal data
set isn't perfect, but it's
getting better every day
from your submissions.
And we have an operations team
that reviews those submissions
and helps remove duplicate data
and fixes bad photos and
things like that.
So I feel like not every game
needs to use this type of
system, but it was definitely
an interesting insight, an
interesting tool that
we used for Ingress.
Another interesting topic, and
we had a lot of discussion
about this, is just the notion
of, should you have all of
your players play in one world
or should you have many
virtual dimensions or worlds?
So this is interesting and,
going back to that slide about
tuning and balancing, it's very
difficult to balance your
game so that it feels fun for
a new player versus the
advanced players who already are
very powerful in the game.
One way to deal with that is
to just create different
virtual worlds.
So maybe all the new players
play together in their
sandbox, and then maybe the
advanced players play in a
different virtual world, these
different dimensions.
And we sort of debated that back
and forth as a team, but
we really wanted this idea.
I guess I felt more epic that
we all played in the same
virtual world so that when your
friend went to Paris and
got that Portal Key from the
Eiffel Tower and brought it
back, it was meaningful to you
versus something where
everyone was playing in
this disjoint world.
So it's just something
to think about.
We're still struggling to
balance things properly, but
that's one of the decisions that
you'll have to make if
you build a similar
type of game.
And think about how you
want to juggle that.
And also, another topic was
launching global versus local.
With some of our apps like Field
Trip, we had a strategy
where we were just going to
focus on where we had good
data in the United States and
launch Field Trip first in the
United States, and then
as we got better data
internationally, we would
roll that out.
With Ingress, we actually
decided to launch
international.
With your games, I think you'll
have to weigh the pros
and cons of that, focusing on
an area that you know versus
spreading yourself out.
But also, the opportunity with
the global game is it can feel
more epic as well.
I love this screenshot of--
I love just occasionally going
to the Com in Ingress and just
looking at all the different
languages, some that I don't
even know what language they
are, and it's fun to think of
all these people in all these
different cultures and all
these different countries
playing the game.
And I think on G+ especially,
you definitely build some
momentum there getting that
critical mass of players if
you launch globally.
Another more technical, but an
interesting thing, is to build
so that your game can scale.
I mean, we all want our games
to be popular, but it's very
difficult to do.
But in the case that it does
grow very quickly, you want to
be prepared for that.
So this is just a pitch for
using Google technologies.
We use Google technologies and
these same technologies are
available to you as developers
as well.
So definitely make use of Google
I/O to learn more about
the cloud infrastructure and
App Engine and all the
different services that Google
makes because these are
technologies that we use and
they do grow with your game as
it develops.
Another interesting learning
that we had from our game was
just the importance
of the story.
The game, it's not just about
the dots and the lines.
The story can help make these
dots and lines feel more
meaningful to you, so you don't
necessarily need to
build an investigation board
like this, but it's definitely
fun to think about, as you think
about equipping your
team of developers-- your
engineers and your game
designers--
you might also want to think
about making sure that you
have someone who's creative and
can help write and craft
that story for your game because
I do think that it
adds a richness to the game.
And then once you have that
story, another tool that I
would pitch is just the use
of YouTube, another Google
company, another Google
technology.
It's a great medium for
reaching people.
It's very easy to have these
videos shared on G+.
We've been doing this Ingress
Report where it's this news
report of that week's events in
Ingress, and it's been very
fun to see the contributions
from players to that, and then
having us basically highlight
the best of
that week on YouTube.
It's been a good way
to reach new users.
We even had a book.
I think this is the first book
published by Google.
We had an author write a whole
story about the Ingress back
story, which was a lot of fun.
$2.99 in the Play
Store available.
Another interesting thing you
can do is you can combine the
story with the game.
We had some events where the
outcome on the battlefield on
the game would actually have a
direct impact on the story.
So we had one where we have this
character named Klue, who
had some videos on YouTube, and
so we had this event in
Scotland and the idea was that
if The Resistance controlled
the William Wallace Memorial at
sundown on a certain day,
then the story would shift and
it was sort of a choose your
own adventure.
So then Klue would be aligned
with The Resistance, and if
The Enlightened controlled that
portal at that time, then
the story would shift and she
would join The Enlightened.
So we felt like it was
definitely an finishing way to
help merge the story with the
game mechanics as well.
And then finally, another
pitch for G+.
We really weren't sure what the
impact would be on G+, but
I mentioned the art contest
that we ran, and it's just
been amazing to see the new
Communities tool on Google+.
It seems like there must
be more Ingress-related
communities than any
other topic.
There's global Ingress
communities, but then down to
local cities and areas for
Resistance and Enlightened.
So Google+ is just a great tool
for meeting new people.
Maybe these aren't already your
existing friends, but
it's a way to meet other
people who share an
interest with you.
So as you're designing your
game, you might want to think
about how you can use Google+ to
get exposure for your game,
but also to build a richer
community with your players.
This was just some
examples of that.
I was always amazed just
to see how dedicated.
The one on the left is actually
a fake tattoo, but
the one on the right
looks real to me.
So that idea of building a
community where your players
can feel a connection
with the game.
And these were just some great
art contributions that I
really liked from G+.
Whenever we were having a bad
day, or there was just a bug,
or things just weren't going
well, you just go to G+ and
you just see stuff like this and
it would just refresh you
as a game designer.
It's so fun to see all the
creative stuff that people
were posting there, and even
more so because it really
aligns with the creativity
and art theme of Ingress.
Art's really the core of Ingress
with the sculptures
and whatnot, So it was
fun to see that.
We had things where people were
knitting things, they
were making things with
physical objects,
photography, cartoons.
Some different memes.
This is another way
to basically get
exposure for your game.
Just embrace those quirky,
funny things that
your fans can do.
We had our team create Ingress
gear, basically anything that
you can do to build that
community with your fans.
Then interactive feedback.
It's hard to see, but this is
a chart of the XM economy in
the game that some player did.
That's something that maybe I
should have done as a product
manager, but I was too
lazy to do that.
So it was fun to see the players
be able to contribute.
And as we tune adjustments,
we listen to the feedback.
So people will say, oh, I hate
what you've done there or I
like what you've done.
We weigh through that and are
able to quickly iterate on the
game and hopefully make
it better every week.
And then G+ is also a great tool
for organizing events.
So we have our Operation
Bowstring
event, of course, tomorrow.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
We have a great party
afterwards.
Make sure you get your drink
ticket downstairs and
everything.
But G+ is a great way to
organize that, get the word
out, and get people
to your events.
And the events, as I mentioned,
is just a great way
to really engage your players
and make them active.
And finally, kind of want to
think about games as a sport.
We were thinking about, how can
you make this so it's fun?
And I thought the example every
weekend, I play in a
weekend tennis league, or you go
to a local park and there's
pickup basketball.
So I'd just challenge you to
think about, how can you think
about a little bit of the
merging between what you think
as video games and what you
think about sports.
Because there's sports like
soccer that they're not that
complicated, but you don't
get bored of soccer.
You play soccer every week.
So especially when you get
these physical games when
you're out moving around, I
challenge you to think about
how you can make a game that
really is simple but is fun.
So we've thought about
incorporating four quarter
periods, different scoring
mechanisms, basically trying
to learn from games like
football and soccer and
thinking about it
in that context.
Think about unique partnership
opportunities in our world.
You can get power ups from
different products.
One option, you could
obviously charge a
subscription for your game or
you could just charge for
game, but I think with these
types of devices and the
technology, there's lots of
opportunities for you to think
creatively about how you can
monetize your game still and
maybe make it free to users.
And then finally, I challenge
you to think about games that
can have a positive impact in
the world, bringing people
together, improving health,
helping people develop
leaderships and skills.
I think that's very rewarding.
And then what's next?
Just challenging you to really
soak it all in here at Google
I/O. Check out Google Glass.
Check out all the devices
and technology, all the
software and tools.
I think as I mentioned earlier,
there's those
technological breakthroughs that
allow whole new groups of
game developers to leapfrog the
current leaders, and so
just think about a whole new
types of gaming experiences
that you can create
using these tools.
And that is it.
So I'll answer some questions,
and then be sure to check out
the game event this week
while you're in town.
And also, we have a booth
downstairs so come talk to us
about the game.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BRANDON BADGER: All right.
First question in the back.
AUDIENCE: So, what is Google
doing with all this data?
What are you ulterior
motives here?
BRANDON BADGER: This is the
classified talk, right?
Honestly, it's to build a fun
experience and a fun game.
I know there's been speculation,
oh, Google could
use this data to improve maps,
and maybe that's the case, but
we haven't even thought
about that, honestly.
I think we're taking the
approach, can we build a new
type of gaming experience?
Some of it is to showcase
the technology.
So something like Google Glass,
there's definitely a
good synergy with these types of
games and Nexus phones and
different types of technology.
I think that's more
what drives it.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: A couple questions
both relating to money.
Have you figured out how much
your run rate is for this
game, if you had to actually pay
for it not being Google?
And then also, have
you figured out--
BRANDON BADGER: We just
use fake money.
AUDIENCE: No, I mean, but you
get your services for free, I
would suspect.
I'm just wondering if you've
figured out what the run rate
would be if you were
an outside company.
BRANDON BADGER: I don't know.
AUDIENCE: And then also, how
have you thought about how you
would monetize the game if
you decided to do that?
BRANDON BADGER: We're still
focused on building a great,
fun game and growing
the user base.
We're confident that if you
build a game like this, that
we can come up with ways
to monetize it.
So as I mentioned earlier, it
might be charging for the
game, it might be subscriptions,
but we're
really trying to avoid that and
we're trying to keep the
game free because we're Google
and we come to things from
more of an advertising
point of view.
So we've been doing some
partnerships with some local
businesses like Jamba Juice.
We think there's something
powerful in helping influence
and encouraging people to go
to a retail location, so we
made the Jamba Juices, we did
an experiment where we made
them portals in the game,
and so we're still
collecting data from that.
We've done a partnership with
Hint bottled water where
there's power codes underneath
the bottle caps that you can
type into your Ingress
app to get power ups.
So I think maybe that's
a way to do it.
But to be honest, we're still
brainstorming what the
business models might be.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I'm
surprised you haven't
mentioned one of the key
findings, and that is that the
Invite Codes should actually
come with spare
batteries as well.
BRANDON BADGER: We could have a
partnership with the battery
makers, right, and just sell
a whole bunch of batteries.
I've got one in my bag, too.
AUDIENCE: Actually, two
questions I had were answered
already, but any plans for
above Level Eight?
BRANDON BADGER: We're
thinking about it.
We're thinking about different
types of missions and
achievements and things.
I mean, it's sort of a rat
race where we could do 16
levels and then 32 levels.
I think you could just
keep doing that.
So we're trying to think of
other ways where we can build
enough head room where you
feel like there's a
progression there, but we're
still debating how far we want
to take it with just leveling
up on the point.
We're still figuring it out.
AUDIENCE: Cheers.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So I think one of the
hardest things to scale is
the human aspect of the game.
So you mentioned that you have
a team of people that's
approving portals.
What's a good strategy
of scaling that?
And I guess the second question
is, how long does
typically a portal get approved
right now in the game?
BRANDON BADGER: It's definitely
taking too long to
approve portals.
There's a couple things that
we're doing to improve that.
One is we're building better
administration tools.
So it was very primitive what
they were using before, but
we're building some better back
end tools where they can
see the photo of the submission,
they can quickly
edit the data and approve
or reject it.
So those tools, they're actually
much more productive
with those tools.
And then we're also hiring
out that team.
I mean, there's different
strategies where maybe you
could have fewer people review
items and whatnot.
But we're trying to balance
the speed of approval with
also quality.
So I think we'll find a better
balance there where we can get
them done a little faster, but
we don't want to start
approving photos of a rock
in your backyard.
We want it to really
still be art.
AUDIENCE: I'm sure a lot of dev
players here have the same
question as me, but can we
expect to settle for sure APIs
coming soon?
BRANDON BADGER: It's something
that we've talked about I
think maybe in the future,
but we don't have
any plans right now.
AUDIENCE: I have a
couple questions.
First off, you had commented on
how a lot of portals are at
works of art, but I know at my
college campus, we initially
submitted works of art and one
person went around submitting
just about everything.
Some of the portals didn't get
approved, some of them did.
So now we have these random
buildings that don't make
sense as portals.
Is there are going to be some
process to suggest portals
possibly be removed?
The issue is now, we're running
into portal saturation
where you can't walk
five feet without
tripping over a portal.
BRANDON BADGER: Yeah.
So the one complaint is the
portals aren't getting
approved and added
fast enough.
The other complaint is when
there's bad quality and things
are getting approved that
shouldn't be approved.
There is a tool in the game now
where you can report what
you think is a bad portal.
If you go into the Portal Info
View and you click on the
photo, and you can report it,
and then that goes to one of
our operators who can review
that and remove it.
It's still a slow process, but
I can promise that it's
something that will improve
and speed up.
AUDIENCE: I saw Bad Title
and Bad Description.
Is there actually just Delete
Portal option in there?
BRANDON BADGER: I think right
now, just flag it just in
general as either a bad
description or a bad portal.
AUDIENCE: My other question
is, what are the plans for
Level Nine and above?
BRANDON BADGER: So as I
mentioned, we're still
debating that internally.
We don't want to turn it into
a rat race where we go to
Level 128, but we're trying to
think of other ways where we
can have progression.
We're thinking about it.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Going back to the
battery pack comment, I'm
wondering if there's anything
being done to
improve battery life.
BRANDON BADGER: It's something
that our engineering team
works really hard on.
I mean, I think a lot of the
energy is probably taken up by
just actually the display
being on.
I think we're brainstorming
ideas, different types of game
mechanics where maybe you can
play with it in your pocket in
certain contexts, and so
you could have the
screen off and on.
We have this Field Trip app that
runs in the background
while your phone is off.
So I think it's something that
we'll continue to improve is
the battery life.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to ask about
your comment on the
[INAUDIBLE].
BRANDON BADGER: So at this
point, Google is definitely a
developer friendly company.
I was a product manager
for the Maps API
for a number of years.
I think we're still in a beta
period, so I think it's
important right now that the
players all use the same tools
and use the official tools.
Part of that is from a
playability point of view.
Some of it is also just our
server capacity, we're still
limiting access to the game so
we still are at a point where
we need to have people use the
official tools just so they
don't hit on our servers
incorrectly.
AUDIENCE: If I have another
question because I am from
Hong Kong and I represent
a part of the
players in Hong Kong.
We found that mocking
is [INAUDIBLE]
now.
And I want to ask if you're
working on something to avoid
mocking of the locations?
BRANDON BADGER: So that's
another thing that our
engineering team is constantly
battling over.
We definitely are working to
prevent people from spoofing
their location while
they play.
So on our servers, we can do
things like if you hack a
portal in San Francisco and
then five minutes later,
you're hacking a portal in New
York, there's things that we
can do on the server side
to detect that.
AUDIENCE: Are you
planning to do--
BRANDON BADGER: He's giving
me the thing.
But thanks everyone.
Come to our party and
play the game.
[APPLAUSE]